to one of my earlier points firstly to
make it clear in the disagreement I
agree with of course I think everyone
knows who I agree with but um I do
because you know what it is though you
know what's actually funny
the things that she's saying are common
knowledge 20 30 years ago this is how
the world functioned this is how the
whole world functioned the things I say
that somehow people believe are
controversial are exactly the way the
world functioned in like the 90s the AES
to 70s all of the entire period of human
history men had a role of masculinity
women had a role of femininity we worked
as a team now the world's come along and
they've destroyed and broken everything
and there's this new Progressive thing
and this new generation of women who
seem to believe that if we completely
[ __ ] it all up it's going to end up
better and my argument to that is listen
we went from walking around in fields in
small nomadic groups to building cities
to building the pyramids to going to the
Moon we managed to go from a few
thousand to billions of people populate
the entire planet build canals build
skyscrapers cities all of this was done
based on the back of man being a man
woman being a woman working together as
a family and I was destroyed now they're
gonna come along and [ __ ] it up if it's
not broken it's destroyed it's been
destroyed man has destroyed Earth what
are you talking about it's been bad
decisions from powerful men that got men
to go to Wars and from women to lose
husbands men built men make decisions
for war men kill men please listen to me
men built the Earth I'm not saying men
are perfect but the entire world that
you're existing under was built by men
yes so so and the point I'm making is
now we're entering a world of new think
and that the problem with new think is
it's not tested I don't give a [ __ ] what
anyone's opinion is what I can State as
a matter of fact is we had 5 000 years
of history that tells us how the world
works with X and Y together we're now
entering a new paradigm There's No 5 000
years of History so whatever you believe
about how it's going to work or it's
going to be better or worse whatever
that's just you guessing everyone is
guessing right so we're renting a brand
new paradigm and everything's completely
[ __ ] up the point you were making
earlier which is a fantastic one about
if I'd pick a woman who's advertising et
cetera et cetera men always please keep
this in mind if you're especially if
you're a female people always say you
know the number of emails I get from
girls who say you don't give enough girl
games I'll give you girl game right now
your man wants status that's what he
wants you need to find a way to make him
look good to the world and to his
friends so how do you do that I'll tell
you one of the ways a man can get status
is to get the girl that no one can get
that's a very simple way right so I said
not ready to mingle I did right okay no
no but this is the truth right if you if
I date a girl
and she's perfect in every way head to
toe and then I'd say I've met this girl
yes she's this she's just oh yeah I took
her for a date even if he didn't [ __ ]
early if you [ __ ] her no no just went
for date so you went the attraction goes
from this to zero done and it may not
for some men because some men haven't
got choices but men like me who
genuinely have unlimited options we want
complete exclusivity that's what we're
looking for because that gives status
that's what you're looking for so you
have to be very careful as a female with
all of your actions all of your
interactions with your boyfriend or when
you're looking for a boyfriend Etc and
say am I gonna make my man look better
by doing X or look worse simple things
I've had endless arguments about girls
nights out right oh you're insecure it's
not about insecure I don't give a [ __ ]
if no man talks to you all night long I
don't care if you're going out and
you're going to an all-girl Club I don't
care I know that when my boys say oh all
the girls are going out and I say not my
girl she stays home I look good that's
it she stays home she doesn't go she
doesn't want she doesn't want to go out
without me that status it's not about
the night out it's about the status of
being the man in the house that's what a
man wants he wants respect he wants to
be the man of the house I say she stays
home she stays home Big G boom boom
that's what we want can I ask you
something what about what does the the
woman want in your eyes what are you
thinking what's the game you get for the
boys I'm gonna tell you but before that
I need another Clementine and I need to
give half to our friend here because she
just rolls her eyes at me and I'm
perspicacious I know it's everything she
doesn't realize that I'm a ninja I
detect these things even when I'm
looking directly ahead I can detect it
I'm gonna give her some of my Clementine
and she's gonna feel better so I'm going
to get Clementine would you like some
Clementine right now I'm sure I just I
think for me it's like I asked you a
question yeah I would love some you want
some Clementine yeah we're gonna hook it
up okay Clementine's coming all right go
on continue okay what no I mean I just
feel like this is definitely a different
conversation for me because I I'm very
open-minded I love hearing different
perspective and I do feel like
um this is a newer idea like like you
said within the last 30 40 years this is
a New Concept we don't know how it's
going to end I just know from from like
my experience other women that I've met
as well it's like the reason for even
like relationships why they're not
lasting is because people don't want to
put up with a disrespect and like even
when you were talking about like oh it's
okay for me to cheat but not for you my
thing is is like why not have
transparency and have it be polygamous
polyamorous whatever works for you
that's like to me where it loses me with
the traditional stuff it's like why
can't we have transparency if I sign up
for that cool so how does it no okay no
no man no man in a millionaire let's all
be realistic right no man and
Millionaire's gonna meet a girl who
likes and go I want to be polyamorous
like come on that's gay let's cut this
[ __ ] so let's let's be realistic how
does a man show love to a woman
exclusivity wrong time resources and
something else time resources so yeah
that's a good that's a good way to start
so sexual exclusivity is how a female
shows primarily primarily that she's
interested in a man he's the only man
who has sexual access to me because I
can get pregnant and I I this man is the
only man who can do it that's how it's
done a man yes I'm not saying all men
can cheat I'm not saying all men should
cheat I'm not saying that I'm saying
that if I truly love a woman she won't
sit there and go he shows me his love
because he doesn't [ __ ] anyone else
she'll sit there and go he shows me his
love because my bills are paid I'm in a
Bentley I drive like private I go to
Dubai anytime I want I have a Chanel bag
and I'm not talking about just money I'm
talking about resource and a lifestyle
as a whole this is not just me this is
the world and most of the world today if
you go to Moscow and you find a big g a
rich guy right he has his wife she's
pushing a Bentley she's the kid she's
living in a mansion whatever when he
goes to the club with his boys you think
he ain't with 19 year old strippers of
course he [ __ ] is she's just like
whatever don't care I'm the one who has
the money don't give a [ __ ] so you have
to sit there and to a point you have to
sit and analyze the the difference when
you're saying disrespect if you're gonna
if you're gonna go through life as a
woman and say I only care about the
sexual exclusivity of my man then what
you're going to end up doing is having a
bunch of failed relationships and
[ __ ] loads of dudes there has to get
a point where you go you know what this
guy takes so many boxes once a year
twice a year he's out with his boys does
some dumb [ __ ] I'm just gonna pretend I
didn't notice because my bills are paid
I'm looked after I can tell he cares
about me if I have a problem he's gonna
fix it he's kicked something that's the
smart female move as opposed to go I
don't care how good he is to me he
[ __ ] that [ __ ] once so I'm gonna
leave and I'm gonna get another man who
I don't love who'll [ __ ] another [ __ ]
anyway and then I'll get another man who
I don't love who [ __ ] another [ __ ]
and the cycle of dumb [ __ ]
I have a question is there ever cheating
that's too far like so if a guy cheats
on a girl is there ever a point where
she yeah there's a lot of cheating
there's completely a lot of cheats like
if he if he knocks up another girl all
right all right so first things first
I'm a man of my word I don't even think
I'm a liar
so here's your Clementine
thank you and he peeled it well thank
you I'm a gentleman right so obviously
I'm not saying blatantly disrespect your
woman right she's your woman she's your
queen she's the most important thing in
the world to you she needs to be
retreated in a way that she feels that
right but it's unfortunate because I
keep tying back to this Baseline point
but the reason I keep going back to this
Baseline point is to try and explain to
everybody at home how simple world the
world can be if you go back to the
baselines of it why do men cheat most
women don't know you'll see them all the
time why do men cheat all because manage
is stupid and why do men [ __ ] girls
uglier than their main chick why do men
do all this stuff you know why I'll tell
you why let's go back to the first thing
I've been saying this whole time status
yeah that's my chick she's home took
this one home yeah I got that one she's
chasing me status status but it's but
it's stupid to females I get it but
that's the male world because sexual
access is an easy indicator of status so
that's one of the reasons they do it
right so you have to go back into the
Baseline of white men even cheat in the
first place I'm telling you if you're a
woman the smartest thing you can do is
look after your man make him not want to
cheat be perfect but there's going to be
a time across a 20-year marriage you
might just need to be a little bit blind
a little bit just a tiny bit just don't
look at his phone
you'll be cool just make sure the bills
are paid he does his job
but this is it we'll talk about that in
a second but I'm not saying allow this
for some [ __ ] Joe Schmo I'm not
saying let some [ __ ] loser pick you
up lock you down I'm not saying that I'm
saying if he's a gene he's doing enough
of his other jobs as for you saying what
if you can pay your own bills then then
what's the reality you face just like I
described earlier I am going to decide
that the thing that I prioritize above
everything above his resource above the
amount he cares for me you'll see men
cheat on a woman and then cry his eyes
out trying to get that woman back he
still loves you it's not the same as if
you cheated he loves you with all his
heart he died for you he would take a
bullet for you and he still [ __ ] that
[ __ ] doesn't matter it's a different
game for men right so you're sitting
here going well I don't I'm going to
prioritize his sexual exclusivity over
all of his other Cal all of his other
attributes you're just gonna end up
having endless failed relationships
bucking too many dudes and then what's
gonna happen is your psychology is going
to break because females don't like to
accept the fact that if you sleep with
enough men and you get rid of the stigma
around a new dick your instant answer is
constantly new dick I didn't text me
today [ __ ] it someone else ah he was
rude to me [ __ ] I'll cheat ah he was
this I was getting a new boyfriend and
then you end up just jumping on [ __ ] all
day and you're [ __ ] done
the reality
Alex boxes you're like you know what I'm
wifey I got the Bentley he does whatever
he does but my bills are paid that's it
when when would you say right now when
would you say it's too far
I'm just curious if there's a line that
you would like if he spends money on
another girl if he like when does it
okay that's a good question another
second question do you think that men
ever fall in love with side chicks very
good question and this is a long and
in-depth answer but it's a good question
let me peel my Clementine but um no but
it's a good question where it's too far
I think public
acting is too far
so like you'll you'll notice let's talk
to Moscow G all right let's take on
oligar a billionaire from Moscow he has
his wife he has the girls he's in the
club with the girls he's in the club
with wouldn't [ __ ] dare message his
wife they wouldn't dare step out of line
like they know their place right so if
there's a hierarchy and they know their
place that's one way of doing it
spending money on a girl certainly yeah
because men show love primarily through
our through our hard work not just
through our resource but through our
hard work if you take a man who's not
particularly Rich he shows his wife love
by getting up every day going to work
nine to five working his ass off and
paying those bills that's how he shows
love that's why he does it for his wife
and his children most men around here
working [ __ ] jobs carrying trash
they're doing that to show love so
giving money yeah that would be a far
more scary indicator than just sex let
me give you all an example I don't know
if you all know my history but I used to
run a webcam business a long time ago
don't talk about it blah blah but I had
a bunch of girls who used to sit online
and talk to guys and they had laptops
right this is a long time ago and I used
to sit and say to some of the webcam
girls that say
this man who is sitting in and logging
in every night and sending you money
every day and telling you he's obsessed
with you from the other side of the
world and missing out on time with his
family to sit here and talk to you and
send you money that is more cheating
than if he just went out and banged
something if he went out and banged
something and came home then done but
he's sitting here giving you his time
his money his affection that's cheating
for a man for a man to sit there and
give money and time away right so you
have to stop this idea of sexual
exclusivity yes that's for females
that's how females show their love to
men it's not how high status at least
males show their love to females and and
anyone who wants to disagree me call me
wrong call me misogynist whatever
[ __ ] look at a history book every
King every Sultan every conqueror every
Emperor every night all of them all of
them had maidens wives all of them
that's that's history what level of G do
you have to be to be allowed to cheat
it's not about even being allowed to
cheat I'm not even saying that and it
also depends on the partner you're with
I'm not trying to sit here and advocate
for men to run around and [ __ ] a bunch
of women I'm not saying that no but I'm
not no no no
what I'm actually trying to do is
describe the Baseline unfortunate
realities of human dynamics
and I'm trying to explain now to the
world that any woman can get a man who
will not cheat on her if she's prepared
to sacrifice a bunch of other things
perhaps right in the olden days it was
different the world was a different
place it was a completely different
place and it was better now it's all
[ __ ] up it's [ __ ] up on every level
and Men especially the high status men
most of them have struggled so hard to
become High status they've been through
so much [ __ ] to get where they are it's
like telling him if you climb this
mountain you can go to a candy store and
he climbs to the top of the mountain and
the second he's in the candy store after
one piece of candy that [ __ ] is saying
no no more candy he's like no I just
climbed this mountain I just got rich I
just went through XYZ I finally got here
I'm finally the candy store now you're
telling me I can only have one piece of
candy okay
do you think do you think that men owe a
woman loyalty if she was there from the
beginning absolutely they absolutely owe
that woman loyal very sexual loyalty
that's what I meant sexual sexual
exclusivity is different men sorry I
mean
sexual exclusivity and loyalty are
completely disconnected for males nobody
wants to talk about this but it's the
unfortunate reality is true I'm telling
you you can get a man he can go on a
holiday and [ __ ] some stripper could
come home and you can lie detector test
him do you love your wife would you die
for your wife would you take a bullet
for your wife that he'll pass the lie
detector test he loves her with all his
heart do anything for her it's just it's
just supposed to say it's not okay
I feel like I guess my question would be
then is like how do you